joining us now with reaction counsel to
the president Kellyanne Conway is with
us all right forget about those people
because it's a joke it's at this point
there are caricature of themselves but
the more important issue is this is this
a fair investigation could you imagine
if this was against the Democratic
president only donors to the Republican
Party people that were texting back and
forth involved in the investigation that
hate one side and love the other side at
some point
Kellyanne you got to say don't we need a
justice system that's fair balanced the
president has always said that he
respects the rank and file at the
Department of Justice in the 35,000 or
so who worked for the FBI but we can't
have a politicization of any
investigation it should be transparent
it should be independent and what you
and James Rosen and other reporters who
care to know all of the facts have
uncovered is very troubling to any any
American who's paying attention this
Peter struck I boys he the busiest guy
in Washington DC I don't know if I've
ever sent 10,000 texts in my life let
alone to one person he's carrying on
this this relationship he's sending
10,000 texts he's putting energy into
being systematically against Donald
Trump which is not his job he is really
at the eye of the hurricane of so much
he is changing the language to protect
Hillary Clinton it sounds like he's
present when her top confidants are
being interviewed he's president when
she's being interviewed this is this is
the entire problem that Americans have
with Washington DC and had with Hillary
Clinton the idea that she's always above
the law there's a double standard and
and Shawn anybody and this includes
everybody who has wasted all of 2017
talking about Russia Russia Russia in
this investigation
they are duty-bound to cover this aspect
of the investigation this guy in the
Department of Justice he's four doors
down from his boss a Deputy Attorney
General he's he's in he's in main
justice he's on the main floor there and
he is meeting after Donald Trump on
which they did not expect and they did
not
want he's meeting with the head of a guy
who put together a dossier using DNC and
Clinton campaign money and trying to
figure out a way to discredit the new
democratically elected president it
stinks to high heaven and look I think
there's so much going on so quickly with
all this information that it's very easy
for Americans to just tune it out or
feel it's confused or it doesn't affect
me what would it be doing for Christmas
what's going on for New Year's I they
will pay attention and part of it is the
media have set a trap for themselves
they've been so obsessed for a year plus
with what they consider to be an
important investigation they've been
talking about Russia and not America but
it also shows something else I want to
say one more thing Hillary Clinton she
already have every advantage possible
all the king's horses all the king's men
she had so much more money so much more
personnel she had all the mainstream
media she had all the Democrats she had
so many people behind her tubes two
presidents her husband and her
predecessor who's who's at who's by the
way whose record did not get a third
term through her candidacy Barack
Obama's she had all these advantages and
then after she loses she still has
advantages she still has people going
for Donald Trump won on the issues he
was a much better brilliant communicator
and messenger his ideas prevailed hers
failed and this idea on his health is
offensive I won't even dignify it except
to say remember when Hillary Clinton
folded like an accordion in front of the
whole world on 9/11 we said nothing
about it the whole day at the campaign
zero she folded in front of everyone and
apparently she had had pneumonia two
days earlier and you know what she did
that night she was at chipper irani with
her high-class donors calling the rest
of us irredeemable and deplorable with
pneumonia then she takes five days off
before the debates Donald Trump's doing
seven rallies a day and showing up to
the debate to beat her she's taken time
off to rest and we're gonna talk about
his health as a joke the man's the most
energetic person I know I do remember
her collapse and a bunch of other issues
that came up during the campaign
Kellyanne good to see you we appreciate
it and yeah thank you so much